la storia siamo noi e dobbiamo farla
dobbiamo farla perché siamo in una fase
particolare siamo ad un bivio estremo da
un lato abbiamo un futuro che può essere
drammatico dall'altro lato abbiamo un
futuro che può regalarci uno
straordinario aumento della qualità
della vita
non c'è nulla in mezzo e chi si obbliga
questa scelta così estrema e l'ambiente
che ci circonda
noi pensiamo all'ambiente
sappiamo tutti che è in situazioni di
degrado come se fosse qualcosa che in
fondo non ci riguarda se perdiamo
l'ambiente perderemo una bellezza ma non
la nostra possibilità di sopravvivere e
ci dimentichiamo che noi siamo parte
dell'ecosistema
se l'eco sistema crolla crolliamo anche
noi è una delle maniere in cui ci sta
già manifestando che questo sta
succedendo è che ci spinge a degli
inediti conflitti adolf hitler ha avuto
un ruolo preponderante nella peggiore
tragedia della storia umana 70 milioni
di morti
solo che la sua vicenda ci ha consentito
di compiere un salto in avanti nella
comprensione della differenza fra la
pace e la guerra sì perché fino ad adolf
hitler si pensava che la questione era
decisa soltanto dall'elite dagli
apparati e mancava dall equazione un
elemento fondamentale cioè la gente
comune
solo che è successa una cosa strana
adolf hitler non ero arrivato al potere
con un colpo di stato ci ha provato nel
1923 è stato messo in prigione ha
scritto il mein kampf in cui ha
dichiarato tutto quello che voleva fare
dieci anni dopo è stato liberamente
eletto
anche se i suoi elettori sapevano
perfettamente che cosa voleva
e allora la domanda si è imposta cos'è
successo
ma è successo che la gente comune conta
la classe media tedesca cioè la porzione
di popolazione in assoluto più istruita
al mondo fra le due guerre ha
liberamente votato adolf hitler perché
era sottoposto a un pesantissimo stress
socio economico causato tra l'altro
dalla crisi del 1929
ecco prendiamo questo ragionamento e
proiettiamo lo sul degrado ambientale in
particolare sui cambiamenti climatici
i cambiamenti climatici sono l'aspetto
del degrado ambientale di cui si parla
di più ma è senza da capire che non sono
né da sony ne isolati chiedo scusa
questo schema che è diventato famoso fra
gli scienziati nel 2009 dimostra nove
ambiti in cui noi rischiamo di
oltrepassare prelevando risorse le
capacità di autorigenerazione del
pianeta in alcuni settori che sono poi
triangoli rossi abbiamo oltrepassato di
troppo
questa soglia di auto rigenerazione del
pianeta
il settore che si riferisce ai
cambiamenti climatici e il triangolo che
punta verso l'alto
situazione grave ma non è la più grave
ce ne sono altri due che sono in
condizioni molto peggiori un è troppo
tecnico il ciclo dell'azoto
ma l'altro lo comprendiamo bene e la
perdita di biodiversità
ebbene dobbiamo capire che siamo entrati
in un ciclo vizioso quanto più il clima
si altera quanto più noi perdiamo
biodiversità
ma quanto più noi perdiamo biodiversità
tanto più il clima si altera e allora la
prospettiva più siamo di fronte e questa
questo è il grafico della perdita delle
specie negli ultimi 200 anni
negli ultimi 50 assolto un'impennata i
naturalisti parlano di grande
accelerazione oppure di sesta
transizione pia ottica transizione di
ottica un parolone per dire estinzione
di massa
siamo nella sesta estinzione di massa
che di si distingue dalle precedenti per
due ragioni la prima è che con certezza
la causa siamo noi
la seconda che non ce n'è mai stata una
così veloce
noi siamo abbastanza familiari con
l'ultimo episodio estinzione di massa
quello che i dinosauri causato
probabilmente dall'asteroide siamo
abituati a vedere i documentari
in cui c'è un asteroide che arriva
colpisce la terra grande esplosione onda
d'urto abbiamo l'impressione che tutta
la tragedia si sia consumata in due
minuti la tragedia c'è stata la perdita
di otto specie su dieci però è durata da
30 a 100 mila anni
ecco se si realizzano alcune prospettive
alcuni scenari di cambiamento climatico
considerati realistici noi perderemo
otto specie su 10 entro la fine di
questo secolo
solo che noi umani siamo meravigliosi
invece di farlo in centomila anni lo
facciamo in 250 da quando si è avviata
la rivoluzione industriale
allora l'oggetto di questa esposizione è
ma a me perché mi interessa il perché mi
interessa ha spiegato molto meglio che
da metà degli scienziati da questo
anonimo pittore di moore al londinese ho
l'onore di presentare il mio desktop
ogni giorno quando vado in ufficio
accendo il mio computer su questa
immagine per ricordarmi per quale
ragione io lavoro ce lo dice lo sappiamo
tutti le api sono sotto pressione se
stanno decimando solo che le api non
sono solo una bella presenza da
contemplare sono anche una funzione
nell'ecosistema ogni pezzo di questo
straordinario equilibrio economico
sistema ha una sua funzione di cui non
possiamo fare a meno
le app impallinano pensiamo a queste è
difficile che noi ci mobilitiamo per le
api figurarsi mobilitarsi per questo si
chiama fitoplancton eppure il
fitoplancton è minacciato da un fenomeno
che gli scienziati chiamano il fratello
dei cambiamenti climatici
anzi lo chiamano fratello malvagio dei
cambiamenti climatici e l'acidificazione
degli oceani
l'effetto serra causato da un eccesso
che anidride carbonica che immettiamo
nell'atmosfera un terzo di questa
anidride carbonica è assorbita dagli
oceani ii diventa acido carbonico che
rende difficile per il fitoplancton
produrre i propri scheletri una funzione
che si chiama bio calcificazione finora
per il fitoplancton è difficile
riprodursi ma ci sarà una soglia fatale
in cui diventerà impossibile e succederà
tutto d'un colpo quando succede il
fitoplancton sparisce la domanda è ea me
non celato mica ce l'ha con il fido più
eppure il fitoplancton alla base della
catena alimentare marina se sparisce il
fitoplancton di conseguenza in tempi
molto rapidi sparisce la vita marina e
ancora una volta ea me mette il 12 per
cento dell'umanità vive di prodotti del
mare il 17 per cento delle proteine che
consumiamo vengono dal mare ma sono
ancora numeri che non fanno paura
il fatto è che la vita marina produce il
55 per cento dell'ossigeno che
respiriamo
allora questi fenomeni si producono in
questo campo
improvvisamente le cause si accumulano
nell'ombra e poi le conseguenza vengono
fuori tutte assieme
teniamo conto di questo teniamo conto
del nostro ragionamento su hitler e
vediamo questo scenario vi mostri
ghiacciai dell'himalaya si scioglieranno
e non si scioglieranno gradualmente in
proporzione al momento alla temperatura
collasseranno per un meccanismo che
sarebbe troppo lungo qui spiegare e la
questione allora ma a me alla perdita
della bellezza del paesaggio alpino gli
hack la cultura tibetana sono perdite
straordinarie ma nulla in confronto alla
perdita della funzione dei ghiacciai i
ghiacciai hanno una funzione regolano il
deflusso delle acque a valle in questa
regione se non ci fossero i ghiacciai e
monsonica il clima sarebbe
caratterizzata da un inter nanza
disastrosa fra siccità e alluvioni
vengono improvvisamente meno i ghiacciai
che in questa regione irrigano piane
dove sono stanziate un miliardo e
400mila persone 400 milioni di persone
queste si trovano in una situazione
simile a quella della classe media
tedesca
anzi la prossimità tedesca ha compiuto
la scelta che ha compiuto perché ha
perso il valore dei suoi risparmi ed
erano 40 milioni
questi perdono acqua riso strade scuole
sanità sono un miliardo e 400 milioni in
un'area in cui quattro stati russia cina
india e pakistan hanno la bomba atomica
huston cui il cada proprio ma forse voi
penserete che questo è un delirio da
politico come sono io lo pensano anche
gli scienziati quelli che tengono
orologio della
calisse 17 premi nobel per la fisica che
nel 2015 hanno posto nella città dell
orologio dell'apocalisse la stessa
distanza in cui erano durante la crisi
dei missili di cuba cioè durante il
peggio periodo di tensione della guerra
fredda
potrete pensare che questo è uno
scenario per il futuro ma purtroppo uno
scenario per il presente
queste sono le zone desertiche del nord
africa qui delle popolazioni si sono
abituate a vivere
compatibilmente col deserto ma
all'interno c'è una fascia una fascia
attiva dove non c'è il deserto c'è la
desertificazione visualizzate la e
sovrappone te la a questa dinamica qui è
dove sono concentrate i conflitti alla
fame
qui è dove sono concentrate le dinamiche
terroristiche qui è dove sono
concentrate tutti i traffici illeciti e
qui e da dove vengono le migrazioni che
ci preoccupano così tanto c'è un'ovvia
coincidenza spieghiamo la in pratica
questo è il lago ciad al cuore del sahel
ha sempre avuto una tendenza storica la
variabilità solo che negli ultimi 50
anni si è ristretto di 18 volte intorno
alla goccia ci sono quattro stati
fragili
chiudete gli occhi e immaginate se il
mediterraneo si restringesse di 18 volte
in 50 anni la nostra economia va in tilt
figuratevi l'economia di quattro stati
fragili e allora non ci sorprendiamo se
prolifera boko haram è in una situazione
di stress che nascono questo tipo di
fenomeni e che nascono quelle origini
certi attentati che ci colpiscono le boe
40 ha avuto il suo ruolo nelle
migrazioni che tanto ci preoccupano bene
ma noi possiamo farcela possiamo fare la
storia
basta la somma di piccole scelte di
sostenibilità di ognuno di noi
per risolvere questo dilemma che con
qualcosa di paradossale
noi possiamo dire bene la situazione
grave quindi mi carico del sacrificio di
cambiare qualcosa
no quello che ci chiede la natura non è
un sacrificio e solo di vivere meglio vi
mostro a due piramidi la prima è
conosciutissima la parola piramide
alimentare la troviamo anche nelle
riviste dal parrucchiere
e quella che ci dice in che proporzione
dovremmo nutrirci di ciascun tipo di
cibo poca carne rossa via via fino a
molte fibre eccetera se noi affrontiamo
questa piramide alla piramide
dell'impatto sull'ambiente della
produzione di ciascuna categoria di cibo
coincidono perfettamente ma nel senso
che quanto più un cibo e nocivo per noi
tanto più la sua produzione è nociva per
l'ambiente sembra una coincidenza non lo
è è il paradigma di come possiamo
rapportarci con l'ambiente potremmo
essere degli obesi di trasporto
meccanizzato individuale la cosa è la
stessa ma questa è solo la punta
dell'iceberg
se noi tutti ci nutriamo non facendo un
sacrificio ma come veramente ci consente
di stare bene creiamo sostenibilità ma
non solo sostenibilità
creiamo anche una ridistribuzione
dell'accesso alle proteine e consentiamo
ai poveri di accedervi ma se noi creiamo
anche questa forma di giustizia noi
creiamo anche la pace perché di un mondo
in cui ogni bambino ha accesso a quella
dose di proteine che gli è necessaria
per andare a scuola
boko haram le migrazioni releases non ci
sono vi ringrazio
[Applauso]